[Music]
foreign
watching The Press preview a first look
at what is on the front pages time then
to see what's making the headlines with
the Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine and
the associate editor of the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire fabulous to see both of
you so as ever let's check out the front
pages shall we for the papers and a
desperate plea from the sinking migrant
boat is on the front of the eye as those
on board cried please help us before
four died and dozens were rescued from
freezing Waters that story also on the
front of the times their headline for
dead after migrant dinghy sinks in
Channel
and The Sun Also covers this Terror at
Sea with a harrowing image of struggling
survivors
the mirror tells nurses we are with you
a pledge they say is from the decent
people of Britain as they prepare to go
on strike across most of the country
tomorrow
give nurses a deal says the Daily
Express they ask to stop this madness
his fears for the well-being of patience
persists Kelly Telegraph fears the
damage of nurses strikes will only get
worse
well the Daily Star jokes tough luck kid
as postal strikes will likely leave
Christmas gifts undelivered the Metro
leads with the tragic story of Zara
Alina their headline just on her walk
home after her killer received a 38-year
sentence for his predatory crimes
on the front of the Guardian a scathing
report condemning the police for victim
blaming in rape cases
and the federal reserve's half-point
rate rise takes the front of the
financial times a shift likely to set
the tone internationally with the bank
of England poised to follow tomorrow
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out those front pages
while you listen to our guests let's
head straight to Kevin Auntie Sarah
welcome to both of you on another tragic
day for the English Channel Kevin
there's the eye please help us
desperately from a sinking migrant boat
and you know thank goodness for those
people that are that a fishing crew is
nearby
no absolutely the trawler which uh which
reckon uh you know rescued a a large
number of them more than 40 according to
the eye of the papers have different
figures of Ft for instance 31 but that
harrowing call at two in the morning to
a charity and the tape of it seems to
have been passed to several newspapers
and a man saying please help us ward has
come in we've got a family on board as a
child heard crying in in the background
it just brings the the fact this is a
human tragedy and it's absolutely
awesome we're all in our hearts will go
out of them but it what do you do about
it and how do we stop the salines and
who were who were these people coming to
start a new life in Britain could there
have been a safe and legal route for
them in which doesn't exist now and look
it's always it's always difficult in
these circumstances but I thought when
the home secretaries uh Braverman called
them Invaders were these people Invaders
the four people she regreted dying did
she think they were Invaders I suspect
not uh I don't think her heart is that
cold old but this will keep on happening
unless there are safe and legal routes
which wouldn't just solve the problem
but a large number mustn't forget people
who do finally get to Britain on these
boats take away take away albanians
although they've been approved so far
but I accept that's a safe country NATO
member but the others often fleeing
persecution elsewhere and they're giving
they're giving um the permission to stay
in Britain because they have legal
claims but it's just when it's almost as
if the government is using the channel
as a moat to try and stop people getting
into Britain to Lodge those claims so as
the sun say they're paying five thousand
pounds they call it a ticket to death
and we're giving the business to the
traffickers because we're not allowing a
legal and safe way into Britain
well there's the uh the times um Sarah
as well a close-up there of the of the
footage that was taken with the sunken
dinghy you can see the people in water
inside that dinghy and uh race track and
the skipper of that fishing vessel said
it was like a war film he spoke to our
correspondent Jason Farrell about it but
it is amazing how sympathetic
politicians suddenly sound on days like
this the government's policy is largely
based on deterrent and there it is those
pictures watching people drown in the
English Channel
oh
yes I mean obviously you know you look
at that dinghy and you just think it's
like a little slipper I mean you know
you wouldn't go paddling in it I mean of
course the people who are really
responsible for this charity are the are
the people traffickers other people who
are taking five thousand pounds per head
to put all those people in that
inflatable
um but and you know the government's
attempts to deter people from coming
haven't succeeded it's you know the
difficulty is is that coming from France
France is not a country that is
considered to be uh you know a dangerous
place and therefore they don't have
automatic Refugee status I don't
understand why the government can't do
some sort of deal with France to process
them
on the other side I don't understand why
they had to be processed when they're
fished out of the sea like this it just
seems it just seems I mean I I know it's
not ideal and I know they shouldn't be
coming but they are coming so at that
point you have to have some kind of
pragmatic policy and it would just be
good if we could perhaps process them in
a place that isn't you know middle of
the channel in freezing cold
temperatures well I mean that's long
been mooted hasn't it that idea of
processing on French soil but a joint
statement tonight with the French as
well abroad man issuing it
um saying that this is a stark reminder
of the urgent need to destroy the
business model of people Smugglers but
then giving some figures um Kevin as
well we have prevented 30 000 Crossings
so far this year and with other European
partners and europol made more than 500
arrests since 2020. I'll also talking
about the closer joint working the
embedding of officers on both sides the
you know greater Tech patrolling of
French beaches do you think the
government's getting your grip on it
perhaps politically you may not agree
with their tone but you think they're
actually trying to do something about it
and should they
well they are but they haven't set up a
system in in France to handle claims
because under the 1951 U.N Refugee
convention you can travel through other
countries to the the country you're
going to seek a safe haven in so they're
allowed to do this we used to be in the
European Union of course and then there
was the Dublin convention which meant
that it could be returned to the country
from which you come from within the
European Union but we're not in that uh
anymore no I think I think she's right
God destroy the business model of the
the people of traffickers and you can
partly do that by cracking down them or
wrestling them imprisoning them saving
their assets uh getting the boats
destroying them however again if you're
not allowing people who will once they
get into Britain be entitled to stay if
you're not going to allow them at the
legal and Safe Way in you are created
and fueling that business model that's
the bit she doesn't get because I think
she just didn't want them to come in at
all she wants to lock everybody out yes
well instantly there was a line from
Rishi Suna yesterday about that the only
way to come to the UK for Asylum he said
will be through safe and legal routes
specific to certain Nations as we know
Afghanistan you know Ukraine Hong Kong
but he did say as we get a grip of
illegal migration we will create more of
these routes with an annual quota in
numbers set by Parliament so perhaps
that is a slight change of tone from the
government in the future very quickly
Kevin I want to move on
where are they until you have until you
have them you will have people
attempting to come across the channel
risking their lives paying paying the
Smugglers and very sadly died it was it
a year ago 27 died that's four now
that's 31 people have died
okay well also on the front page of the
times which we saw there is the news
about uh and the nursing Union lining up
the prospect of longer walkouts
certainly
um the head of the Royal College of
Nursing uh told us this evening that the
strikes May well go into January which
takes us to the uh Daily Mirror you
cared for us when we needed it most now
the decent people of Britain say to our
nurses we are with you but so people are
scared about this aren't they
yes I think it's interesting though
because I think there's a lot more
sympathy for nurses than for almost any
other sector
of people striking I think that people
genuinely feel that nurses are underpaid
um and if you look at the numbers they
are pretty much underpaid and of course
they you know they don't get any you
know they work extraordinary long hours
and very difficult circumstances and I
think they are
I I think the mirrors actually I think
it's a note there because I do think
people really sympathize with nurses I
mean whenever I've had any interaction
with the NHS whether it's been me or my
children the nurses have always just
been amazing and you just think gosh
they just do such an incredible job and
they just do get paid very little so I I
think I I think that I mean I know that
sympathy is waning for other sectors
that are on strike but I think as far as
the nurses are concerned I I think
people do have a lot of sympathy and I
think that hopefully they'll be able to
get I mean you know if I were the
government I think I would just you know
give them a bit of a deal
um and just help them out really to what
level I mean we saw in Scotland there
was a deal wasn't there 7.5 more if
you're on the lower bands I know so what
is it Sarah what does it do what what is
what is the right price if I can put it
that way I don't really know but I said
to Kevin last week actually we were
talking about this and I said I would
just give it eight percent and and just
you know hope that that would happen you
know get them somewhere some way towards
what they want I mean I I know that you
know that is below the the the inflation
rate but I mean I think you know
everybody else is is having the same
problem but I just think they just need
some sort of quite you know generous
gesture
yeah I know I'll be happy for Sarah to
do the negotiations but if those uh
trade unions in the Royal College of
Nursing which is holding the first
strike in England Wales and Northern
Ireland of this nature in its history
more than 100 years but if it's settled
in Scotland for seven and a half percent
a bit more for for lower paid workers
you could see that is where you do the
deal elsewhere and if you look at the
express the express is probably the most
faithful mouthpiece of Downing Street
and cheerleader uh for the conservative
party they're saying give nurses a deal
and stop this madness and they point to
a pole and you know Sarah touched on it
uh public support for nurses polling
that 52 to 27 back the nurses this is
where I think the government is going to
lose and Steve Barkley the health
secretary is playing is very very bad by
not getting into talks about pay and if
he had earlier in the week this strike
wouldn't be happening tomorrow it just
wouldn't it wouldn't be happening okay
we'll see what happens um whether the
government
um you know comes back to the table or
the employers as they like to say and
just quickly I'm going to run through
the Daily Star
um it was on the front I think it was
the telegraph last night actually the
fact that foxes are crawling all over
abandoned uh Royal Mail postal sachets
because well who knows what's in those
gifts possibly in there maybe some food
also needs to cough I'm going to do the
story very quickly because we're running
over sorry anyway tough luck kid your
presents have been eaten by Foxes and uh
obviously many many businesses impacted
by the strikes underway in both Royal
Mail and um the railways as well
um but we move on we've got lots to pack
into the next part of our program
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again the
Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine and the
associate editor of the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire welcome back to both of
you
um and just a simply awful story on the
front page of the Metro Sarah just on
her walk home the case of Zara Alina
um and the man who murdered her who was
a predatory Prowler that night as we
heard in live television sentencing
today
I know this story is horrendous because
he tried to get two other women that
they know of that night so he just
that's what he went out to do he went
out to to get to get a girl and you just
think oh you know the amount of times my
daughter walks around London on her own
you know there but for the grace of God
it's just horrific I I I don't
understand this I don't understand how
somebody can be like that it's just so
weird I just yeah these these men who
are you know you you you tend to not
believe that they exist but look at him
he does exist
um 38 years he's got I don't know that
that's quite enough to be honest I don't
think he should ever be let out again
well we moved to the guardian Sarah just
quickly on a related matter um this is a
report on how police tackle rape
um The Guardian suggestion suggesting
rather it's exposed persistent failings
in the Criminal Justice System including
a failure to track repeat suspects
explicit victim blaming which is their
headline and botched investigations none
of which will give Comfort to those
women as you say trying to get home of
an evening
yeah because also you know these the men
like that they're probably you know
they've probably tried to do something
like that before so it's very important
when women make reports that you do try
and join up the dots and see if there is
any correlation between you know
previous instance I think I think you
know you should be innocent until proven
guilty absolutely
um but I also think that you know you
need to take women seriously because you
know the idea that uh you would be
victim blamed automatically will put
people off reporting things and it's
only by women report even if a woman
reports an incident that didn't maybe
lead to a rape but that was a sort of uh
you know a a case of someone stalking
them or following them home that could
be significant because we saw with this
guy you know with Zara's killer and he
tried it with two other women failed and
finally got her so if one of those other
women had called the police and said
look some weirdo followed me around the
place into a grocery store and then Then
followed me home and they just went oh
well she's obviously just making it up
she's what I mean I mean there are times
when these things are important so it is
it is quite important for the police to
to have to be open-minded about such
things and of course there are cases
where women report rape when it's not
true but I I think most of the time
especially if they end up having to go
to the office at the station and make a
report they're not doing it for fun
they're doing it because something's
actually happened okay you've got 10
seconds on the Ft
um interest rates Kevin
yeah the U.S feds put them up by half a
percent instead of uh this 0.75 recently
Bank of England European Central Bank
expected to follow interest rates are
going to go up people are going to
refuel The Squeeze gonna hit their
living standards again you're going to
have higher mortgage costs but they may
not go as high as was feared when the
conservatives on the list trust and
quality quarter and crush the economy
yes and uh inflation falling still in
double figures of course as we found out
today um both of you thank you so much
Sarah Vine and Kevin McGuire thank you